[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rando pays vous propose cette
découvrir un petit bijou du cirque de
silos le bassin la roche dans la ravine
fleur
[Musique]
jaune rendez-vous àos sur la routeilord
au départ du sentier vers le col du nous
y retrouvons jérme Turp accompagnur en
[Musique]
mon
petit trésor en plein cœur du cirque de
silaos le bassin la roche s'atteint
facilement depuis la cascade de Bras
[Musique]
Rouge pour la rejoindre deux options
sont possibles l'une au départ de silos
même la plus facile et l'autre départ du
pied du par un sentier un peu plus long
mais plus poresque et qui offre parfois
quelques
[Musique]
surpris c'est surtout un sentier avec
des passages à flan de falaise qui offre
de beau points de vue sur le
[Musique]
C
et le fond de la ravine de Bras
[Musique]
Rouge c'est aussi l'occasion de
découvrir le python de sucre sous un
autre angle ce Pain de Sucre le python
de sucre aussi on peut l'appeler c'est
une ancienne chamb magmatique qui date
de 200000 ans qui été refroidi en
profondeur et puis l'érosion avec le
temps l' mis aller à lib avoir une
chambre magmatique qui est aussi dégagé
que ça si intact que ça c'est quand même
assez voire même très très rare au monde
faut s'imaginer que la chambre
magmatique quand il s'est refroidi
c'était plein donc le refroidissement
est devenu très très compact et tous les
alentours de cette chambre magmatique
est devenu très poreuse l'érosion l' mis
aller à libre et ça fait comme si on
démoulait un glaçon d'un cube quoi et ça
donne
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça
juste avant d'arriver sur la cascade de
Bras Rouge un replat au milieu des
Chocas est le point de repère pour
trouver le départ du sentier marron vers
la ravine fleur jaune
ouvrez bien les
[Musique]
yeux de sentier sauvage et non balisé
n'est pratiquement pas
[Musique]
aménagé en dehors de quelques mains
courantes en cordes il faut donc être
très
[Musique]
vigilant au bout d'une petite demi-heure
c'est l'arrivée au bassin la roche
véritable piscine naturelle nichée au
cœur de la ravine fleur
jaune
[Musique]
on peut s'y baigner profiter des
toboggans ou encore sauter à l'eau en
toute sécurité la profondeur est
suffisante attention ne pas trop
s'approcher du casser pour autant un
lieu idéal pour se ressourcer et se
[Musique]
détendre
ce que j'aime dans cette randonnée c'est
l'accès on sent un peu des sentis battus
qu'on trouve pas mal ici à la Réunion là
on sent un peu des sentis battu donc
c'est un peu c'est on va dire c'est un
peu la jungue quoi c'est un peu un vouer
et le deuxième point intéressant de
cette randoau c'est quand on arrive sur
le secteur de bassin la roche c'est la
quantité de petits bassins de petits de
petites cascades où on peut se
rafraîchir se baigner faire fait un peu
les fous comme on dit chez nous dans
l'eau silaoienne les bassins sont très
très sécurisés il y a toujours de l'eau
seulement période sèche où le débit
baisse un petit peu donc voilà mais on
peut dire à 100 % qu'il y a de l'eau
tout le long de l'année la partie qui
descend de ta Beit à Bras Rouge
effectivement c'est un peu plus un peu
plus aérien et on a de nombreux points
de vue sur le siècle de silaos et sur la
sortie du cècle de silos qui est qui est
formidable quoi le seul petit point
négatif je dirais de cette de cette
randau c'est la chaleur hein donc quand
on commence à attaquer ce sentier là
vers les 11h du matin le soleil est
quand même assez haut là la température
peut peut monter jusqu'à les 34°grés
facilement quoi donc de l'eau faut
amener une grosse quantité d'eau et de
la crème solaire et les
[Musique]
chapeau